evan bryn thanks for coming on the show
thanks for having me man
i'm so pumped me too man
it's been uh exciting just to hang out
for the last hour or so
likewise yeah yeah yeah we have a lot of
awesome
topics we have football
we have the journey we have cannabis
healing properties for things like cte
we have consciousness god metaphysics
the big questions as well maximizing
human potential
a lot of good stuff lined up
so far so fun all right let's start with
the journey yeah
was it burbank right is where
you're raised um
middle school and high school yeah i was
born in new york city
lived in brooklyn until i was 10. my mom
moved my brother and i out to l.a
burbank um
around 97 98
so i went to middle school and high
school in burbank california
the dream to play football
and to play in the nfl started when i
was about
seven or eight at my grandparents house
in connecticut
watching on the news the jets and the
giants and training camp
um i just thought to myself i want to be
one of those gladiators you know i want
to be one of those warriors that
goes and competes goes to battle every
sunday and
my mom would never let me play she was
she was worried i'd get hurt
for good reason um
but finally my freshman year of high
school
i with the help of my dad convinced her
to let me play
and uh that was it man you know
everything from that moment on every
how i thought how i carried myself how i
ate how i trained
the way i
lived was in alignment
to reach the top of that mountain which
was playing in the nfl
so um you know and i was very blessed i
was surrounded by great people you know
my mother
both my parents were very
intuitive holistically minded people
food is medicine exercise drink plenty
of water
use whatever natural means are available
before going to a doctor to be
prescribed some sort of
medication or whatever it might be
so that really infused my
athletic life and
uh pretty shortly thereafter i don't you
know my mom was so
she's a you know we come from this long
line of mystics my
earliest american ancestor is a woman
named mary bliss parsons she came to the
us or came to america in
1630
with her husband coronet joseph parsons
she was on trial for witchcraft three
times
um and really i mean when you break it
down was witchcraft at that time it was
being in tune with nature you know
living with the earth
being disconnected from the stark
ice-cold religious
um you know philosophy
of the era and so you were women in
particular were cast as witches and
she got off every time lived to be in
her 80s
had 11 kids one of them named eben
he was killed in a battle with indians
at the age of 21.
um and
yeah so i think all of that
this internal knowing this understanding
of how the body works my mom
you know i grew up my mom had a lot of
really interesting
there's a lot of darkness in my
childhood my parents getting divorced a
lot of mental health issues
depression anxiety alcoholism
substance abuse um and uh
you know so that my childhood was laced
with a lot of darkness a lot of um
difficult times but in the midst of all
of that
my mother and my father who you know
my dad was always sort of a beacon of
light even in his
sort of on
[Music]
inability you know to you know he was
very much
dealing with his own [ __ ] his own
darkness at the time as well but he was
always a very stable force while my mom
was in a very difficult time
but even through that i remember she was
she had this boyfriend and
as difficult of an environment as this
guy
created he also with my mother they
would go
to these cadaver studies
and they would do autopsies and look at
the human body and learn about it and
she had all these books of anatomy and
it really
gave her this very intricate
understanding of the human body and how
it works
uh from a kinesiological perspective to
a physiological perspective she really
understood how
to get the body out of pain
which was incredibly
important in my early career as a
football player
and especially as a young kid i had a
number of growth spurts
that wreaked havoc on my back
my back was always going out when i was
a kid i mean i was
you know i remember being 11 12 years
old
and my back would go out i couldn't walk
you know and i'd be
laid out on my back on the floor and my
mom knew exactly
what exercises to do
to get out of pain to get back on my
feet
and you know my dad was always very
intuitive with that as well so i was
very blessed and
when i was freshman year of high school
i'm playing football
and my mom would drag me and my brother
to yoga classes
so that was sort of you know along with
the brutality of the collision sport
that i was
you know just starting on starting on
this adventure
into football i had this great
foundation of holistic healing
and ancient knowledge
of and at the time was very intuitive
because since
then you know i i had no idea that yoga
could be so
beneficial but it intuitively
it made me a better football player you
know it made me
more in tune with my body made me more
resilient
less prone to injuries so i'm very
grateful for that
so that's that's where the the football
dream started man
and the lineage of mystic tradition
which is so interesting yeah that
almost 400 years ago you're coming from
this deeper spiritual mysticism that
then sort of bubbles up
in your lineage to your parents which
then
you take on intuitively which makes
sense
today that you are who
you are because it wasn't just
undergoing the process of it wasn't just
football
you fell in love with creative writing
yeah which also makes a lot of sense
with the mystic tradition and then and
that's why
i would also say that you're a really
good writer because you can find on his
website
you can find really good or well
articulate
writing and then also that you knew that
growing up you know
i mean phil jackson and and the bulls
also you know he made yoga
yeah a priority yeah and yoga means
union
in sanskrit union with what the divine
your own
unique relationship with the divine yeah
with both the unity
of everything and also the unique
self-actualization of your gifts
and so of course it makes people better
athletes right of course it makes people
better
creatives better parents better
everything yeah
and so that's beautiful and makes a lot
of sense
yeah and so do you feel like you're
when you are sort of
having this embedded mysticism within
your lineage which is so beautiful and
crucial i love that
that that was kind of one of those main
influencers not only in
balancing out football with
yoga so you had that style but you also
had balancing it out with
you know creative writing do you feel
like that was one of the key influences
in you picking that up
yeah it's so interesting talking about
this because uh
you know every time i do an interview or
i talk to someone about
my life or my history my past my path in
the football and out of it
things come into more clearer context
you know because at the time i've only
recently only in the last couple years
learned about my my deep family lineage
and part of that is in my purpose in
this lifetime which is rectifying a lot
of my family pain and trauma
um absolutely
you know to answer your question from
the time i was a little kid
i had this sort of intuitive
understanding
of things and that's not to say that
i had it all figured out or i haven't
made
immense amounts of mistakes and
been through tons of chaos and created
chaos
throughout my life but i had this
understanding of sort of
how to do it what it was i was always
looking for you know ram das talks about
this thing
where you know he spent so much of his
life searching for the people who
searching for someone who knows who knew
you know
knows what it's all about you know and
as little kids we look up at adults and
we go
they know they know what it's about and
then you become an adult you're like
these people don't know a [ __ ] thing
you know and so it if you're a seeker
which you know at the very
the most distilled finest point
of what my life is all about i'm seeking
i'm constantly seeking
um for the diamond necklace that is
already around your neck
exactly exactly exactly right
um yeah it's like that perfect balance
between knowing you are already it yeah
but also knowing that we're a work in
progress always
absolutely absolutely yeah yeah
um
so you know i had this really
beautiful blend of and that's who i am
as well which is really interesting for
instance my birthday october 14th
is the day of moderation in this
birthday
astro astro astrology book that we have
it's pretty funny and it's to the t what
what my day is you know it's
i'm a libra to the utmost the scales
i'm four days before i'm you're the 10th
october 10th libra and your the day of
moderation
very deeply aligns with your middle path
exactly metaphysics
exactly you know so as you start to
for me as i've learned about myself as
i've taken looks at my life
as i've you know been given
distance from this thing this everyday
reality of you know being in this
constant state of trying to
do things succeed attain
produce create aspire
etc and you can
for me through the practice of
meditation yoga
breath work psychedelic experiences
it's given me this great distance to be
able to look at my life and go wow i'm
exactly who i am
you know this is exactly who i am and
the stars say it so as well
um so you know my grandmother is an
academy award-winning actress her name's
estelle parsons
she won best sporting actress and bonnie
and clyde
her husband my mother's father who i
never met his name is richard gaiman
he's a famous american writer
wrote countless stories for playboy
magazine wrote a number of books
my father's a painter he's an artist
as well as he was a very accomplished d1
basketball player at jacksonville
university
ironically
you know my mother ran a handful of
fashion magazines
you know i say all of this because in
the midst of
my also you know my parents got divorced
i spent tons of time like i said up
with my grandparents in connecticut and
my dad's three brothers
my uncles and
these men were saints you know
for the most part as far as what they
meant in my life
and my brother's life and what they did
for us and
i mean we would spend three months of
the summer up in connecticut
we did nothing from sun up to sun down
it was all sports every sport under the
sun that you could think of
and in that experience in the midst of
going outside and shooting hoops all day
or throwing the football around or
going to the baseball diamond and you
know hitting countless balls and
fielding grounders and all of it
there were art books there was great
literature there was
um a recognition of the great thinkers
of the world
you know so i had this beautiful blend
of
brutal physical competition with
very high level
uh artistic philosophical
thinking um makes perfect sense
right i love that right and so it was i
feel really blessed to have had that
you know and some somehow
my football career was going exactly as
it was supposed to
um you know given
my trip my mind's eye trajectory because
i really had it and
it was visualization you know i said i'm
going to be
i'm going to play in the nfl one day
that's right you know and people would
say oh that's fun that's cool ed but
what's your plan b and i'd say there is
no plan b
you know that's what i'm going to do the
north star was
very clear yeah and he'll think and grow
rich you had that
visualize and the universe fills it in
yeah yes yes and i knew you know
and uh exactly i put it into my mind's
eye
my mind put my body into action
yep you know and so that took care of
itself and i was surrounded by the right
people and did the right things
and everything came into alignment and
somewhere around my
sophomore year of high school i fell in
love with writing
and then i found this writer bretty
stenellis who's written less than
zero and a handful of books they're
really fun
it's like you know very drug-induced his
first book less than zero he wrote
in like a crack ben bender
at bennington college in his creative
writing program
in two weeks and i was like
wow you can major in creative writing
that was where it kind of sparked this
idea
and i said okay i want to find a college
that made has creative writing as a
major
so i'm getting tons of offers around my
junior year going into my senior year
i've got you know
50 scholar full scholarship offers from
schools all around the country the whole
pac-10
oklahoma tennessee you know lsu
and it really came down to who had a
creative writing program in arizona
i went on a trip to visit there they
were very
aggressive in their pursuit of me
um which i appreciated and i liked the
guys there and i liked what they were
doing
i liked how they talked but i came in i
went to a visit there and the woman who
was giving this presentation about what
school offered said
well we have a creative writing program
that's top 10 in the country some people
think it's the best in the world
i said boom that's it yep you know
um so i chose arizona because i can
major in creative writing i could play
football i could be part of this
building a legacy which has since sort
of been
completely obliterated by the
administration of arizona unfortunately
but i could really be a part of this
thing and i could do what i wanted to do
off the field
you know which was major and creative
writing and pursue
my artistic passions as a storyteller
[Music]
so there you go makes so
much sense looking back and connecting
the dots because as you're talking about
being up in connecticut you have your
three uncles
you guys are going hard on all the
different sports which is fantastic for
the body
fantastic for coordination for so many
different aspects
to aesthetic and physical yet it's
balanced perfectly with art with
literature with philosophy with the
greatest thinkers
that style of balance is that synthesis
of science and spirituality or of
athleticism and
in spirit that's really powerful
and it makes so much sense leading up to
why you know you had this profound
moment sophomore year you're like
i can do creative writing it makes sense
going to arizona for
a program that could fulfill that
passion and creative writing that north
star
that process was really beautiful
hearing you talk about that
something that we're obsessed with on
the program is catalyzing other people's
both self-realization of the unity of
all being in existence but also the
self-actualization of their unique north
stars which really require that style of
there's no plan b don't ask me about
that
yeah and i know that i have to grind and
work hard every day
but that's the fire under my butt that
excites me it brings me meaning and
fulfillment every day to achieve that
transcendent noble aim yeah of mine
it's really interesting this thing you
say that
because these are such manufactured
ideas it's like plan b
and what you're gonna do with your life
it's like is there a plan b
to your purpose on the planet you know
what i mean yes i do
this is such nonsense that we've created
in our sort of
i don't know what it is it's the
industrialization of the human mind
you know it's we've been civilized out
of our humanity
you know like we're talking about um
like talking about you at 19 being at
the university of minnesota
and saying dude how do i make this
happen
and the guy goes well come out to
silicon valley dude you know and
your your rational mind your conditioned
culturated mind is going no man i gotta
finish this degree
i gotta because that's the line of
that's a trajectory to get the job i
want and all
etc it's like no man we're not here to
try and
figure out what we're supposed to do
with our lives
i said this the other day and i post
you know i watch nature all the time and
obviously as a student of
you know the great mystics
i'm watching these hummingbirds in my
backyard and they're just
floating from flower to flower
collecting nectar does
anyone would they have no shadow of a
doubt of what they're doing
with their life ultimately there's no
nihilism everything has deep
meaning and purpose and you came here
with an intention to flower
a specific sole purpose an artistic
execution and actualization into the
world and when we take it from that
angle
it makes it much more evident
for us as we're waking up and piercing
the veil
over time it's thinning and thinning and
thinning
and then we realize more and more our
own true nature of our awareness and
consciousness
and we also realize what our true north
star is and how there's absolutely
nothing to do besides that that's the
only
purpose is those realization and
actualization
yeah we can we can unpack
yeah as we as we go yeah you've
what do you think that is why do we
why are so many people stuck in
not being able to
access that or see through that it's
just layers of distractions
it's likely the way we purposely
designed the reality to be that way
because it makes it
fun because if you came knowing yeah
yeah so we come forgetting and then as
the greek said it's
an amnesia or remembrance that occurs
when we remember
what the true self is that we share that
infinite self
yeah and that we are here to bring a
gift
yeah we're here to bring it together
well what's the opposite of remembering
this amnesia well we come in
dismembering there you go we come in
dismembered and we remember
and we remember yeah yeah yeah we
usually say forgetfulness
amnesia and remembrance and amnesia
and this would be a good way to
to bring up like what was going on
was that you you lined up this
really interesting alignment of the
stars in your own life
where you had a familial mystic
tradition that made it really clear
that you had this perennial spirituality
that was kind of built in in art
and literature and philosophy great
thinkers but also you had this
incredible
harder physical sport
athletic science side of things at the
same time that you're balancing that
with
and then that kind of led you into the
football the creative writing
the which also ended up in a sense as
you're kind of getting through arizona
this is kind of maybe one of the more
interesting transitory moments because
you had this north star of the nfl draft
but
that there's this there's this also
strange
i don't know if you were feeling it at
the time in arizona but that there's a
strange like
what am i actually putting my body
through in this process
and only later downstream do we realize
things and become an advocate like you
are today for cannabis to heal rather
than opioids
and cte and all these problems with
the actual physical vehicle of the body
after it goes
undergoes concussions and all of these
devastating physical injuries and so
were you feeling that
also at the time at arizona too
i was very much in a
warrior manifest destiny mindset
at that point you know this was my
life i'd really come to embody
the persona of being a warrior
being a gladiator so
you know from the time i was a sophomore
in high school
my right shoulder would subluxate it
would pop in and out of the socket
and i wasn't a full dislocation because
it would literally slide out and slide
in
excruciatingly painful and i played
through that for years and years and
years
and it would happen at least once a
season and i knew how to deal with it i
knew how to manage it i knew how to
do all the little exercises to keep the
the tiny muscles in there the stabilizer
muscles
strong and healthy so that i could keep
playing and doing what i
had had to do to play at a high level
so i was really for a long time there
was
i was functioning with great reckless
abandon as far as my body and mind went
you know
and i lost connection with myself
you know through the process of chasing
this dream
chasing this idea of making it to the
nfl
when i got to the nfl finally in 2009 i
was drafted by the jaguars
39th overall in the second round
[Music]
and you know
football for me was always a very
it was always a love-hate relationship
you know i loved it because it was this
place
where i could exact
my rage my inner rage and fire on
others and be celebrated for it
uh i could physically dominate people
and be praised gladiator you've been
saying that
yeah yeah and uh but at the same time it
was super painful
it's a grind football is really
difficult yes
you know but i loved that enough
that that kept me going and i had
something to prove to the world i had to
show the world
through the darkness of my childhood i
had to show the world how much i was to
be feared
how scary i was how tough i was how
badass
i was so football was my vehicle to
prove that
to everyone else and then i get to the
nfl and i realize
[ __ ] i'm still not enough for myself you
know
i haven't proven anything you know at
the end of the day
i've been an all-american i've been
all-conference i've been all this i've
been
team captain every year that i've ever
played football and
here i am and i'm still not enough for
myself i'm still
you know now i've as the as
the you know the the mission progressed
i had the house i had the car now i had
the family i had a beautiful wife i had
a child
people loved me and i wasn't enough you
know for me
um and so this process of deconstruction
happened and you know in the mind body
um oh show you know osho yeah
one of my other favorites you know he
talks about how there's no disconnecting
the mind and the body it's one thing
the mind-body vehicle uh and when you
think about that
rationally or from a logical standpoint
it makes sense right i mean you don't
think about opening and closing your
hand you just do it it's all part of the
the you know the synergy between the
mind and the body it's just one
thing that's that's in constant flow
and that transcends to
emotionally and psychologically
psychically all the things happening
they transcend into your physical
tissues so my body started breaking down
you know as first i dislocated my
shoulder my second year in the nfl
was done for the season all that
subluxating finally it fully dislocated
against the kansas city chiefs
that was also during a time where i just
blown out my back
so going into my second year i herniated
the disc in my back l5
s1 had excruciating elf uh
sciatic pain running down my leg causing
numbness in my right foot
i was in an immense amount of pain
coming into the facility at
5 30 6 o'clock in the morning get
treatment get in the hot tub get rubbed
down
get this get that just to get myself
into a state where i could
play and i was starting a right tackle
so it was a bit of a gift from god a
gift from the universe at my shoulder
against the kansas city chiefs week
seven or eight i fully dislocated my
shoulder
i dislocated it in one play popped it
back in finished the drive
came out told our athletic trainer i'm
like dude i need a
i need a shoulder stabilizing strap
a shoulder sl harness because we're
about to go out for a two minute drill
before the end of the half
and he's like i'm like hurry the [ __ ] up
because i gotta get back on the field
so he runs gets the shoulder harness
laces me up
tightens it in i'm like okay i'm back
out on the field
two plays in i'm past blocking shoulder
goes out again
this time i can't get it back in so i'm
running off the field
in the in the midst of this two-minute
drill
three team doctors couldn't get my
shoulder back in for about
three or four minutes you're like ed can
we get you into the locker room like
[ __ ] no
just put it in
oh finally they get it in
take me into the locker room
i probably took some vicodin you know
got undressed
put my sweats on went back out onto the
field i'm in this haze of
opiates and i've got a massive dip in my
mouth
and i'm just thinking to myself i'll be
ready for next week yeah
wow you know that's nuts and it wasn't
until after that game where
i went in and met with the team doctor
and he said you know you're
you're done for the year i can't let you
go back out and play you need to have
surgery yeah
to fix this and uh
you know that was the first time of my
entire football career so that's my
second year in the nfl
where i wasn't going to be able to play
because of an injury
and that you know that was a big moment
that was a big
humbling experience but i was still
in the warrior mode i'm like okay i'll
have surgery i'll come back next year be
even stronger
you know so you know my body over the
next couple years my back was a big
issue
and then the next year the lockout
happened
so the owners locked the players out
because we couldn't come to terms on a
new collective bargaining agreement
so i went back to arizona finished my
degree wow
got rehabbed in my shoulder meanwhile my
back is still a mess
i hadn't addressed it yet still have
sciatica running down my leg
um and uh insane
it's funny when i'm growing up i have my
friends that are
playing football because i'm gonna play
playing different sports but i didn't
play football but my friends closest
friends that are playing football
telling me about all these stories about
because some of them are literally
playing tackle
and when you're playing tackle you're
doing this motion
where you're you're stressing the [ __ ]
out of your shoulders when you're on the
other
players and you're on offensive tackle
you have the defense as well that's
pushing
and you guys are doing this motion and
they're you know that whole thing with
the whole pop in the shoulder and then
like it's like oh it's not a problem at
all and then you just like put it back
in place and you're like i got this
uh coach you know and the and the
doctors and
yeah the like you're saying there's this
vicodin and
like for pain killing and then like
you're just like doing the gladiator
mode like i'm ready for next week
yeah and it's so interesting hearing
about
that perspective of that
in many ways it also resonates as like
this entrepreneurial grind where people
just treat
as you were saying their mind body yeah
as
nonsense where really it's that soul
vehicle where
you have to have which we'll talk about
in a bit but your
obsession with that nutrition that sleep
that exercise
those the combination of that along with
your north star is the only sustainable
way to actually do it
yeah yeah yeah so all of that gets
thrown out you know
it gets thrown out of whack and you're
out of alignment and
then things start to get [ __ ] up you
know your shoulder dislocates you
herniated disc in your back
you become injured you know and so
that was really the beginning of my
complete
obliteration mental physical emotional
spiritual um but the trauma leads to the
treasure
exactly so cool exactly exactly right
so you know i had a few more years of
that uh
the next so the next year was the
lockout
shoulder was better training camp starts
because we
we didn't have any spring because the
lockout no spring otas
so we came right into training camp and
uh
it was really it was evident right away
you know my back was still an issue i'd
come in
i'd be in there for two or three plays
i'd come out you know i couldn't feel my
right leg
i was just a mess and my head coach jack
del rio god bless him i love him to
death
he said ebb you got to just have back
surgery man you know
at that point i had a number of epidural
injections right
into my spine that did nothing
um so i said okay i'm gonna have back
surgery so i had back surgery
that was life changing took me right out
of pain woke up the next day
woke up at a surgery and felt like
someone pulled the piece of glass out of
the circuit board
wow and wow
herniated discs are a huge pain
hugely painful and sciatica is hugely
painful yeah
yeah it was brutal it was the most
brutal pain i've ever experienced i mean
it would be blinding at times
you know literally blinding like it
couldn't i couldn't i
couldn't see couldn't drive a car um
so like that pulled a piece of glass out
of the
it was brilliant you know so
but wait
um so come out of surgery they want to
get me
rehabbed quick and rehab was pretty
quick for that
the recovery was pretty fast um
which i started on basically right away
the only issue is i came back i was
feeling great back to my rookie
level production
i started i they i came back we needed
somebody to play left guard i moved into
left guard never played left guard in my
life
play six games of the year and they're
like ebb you're on track to be an
all-pro
this is like you're [ __ ] dominating
so it's about week seven or eight
this is 11 weeks after surgery we're in
pittsburgh to play the steelers and i
can't get out of bed
whoa my back is completely seized up
whoa
whoa and it took another month so i
couldn't play that
i tried my damn i went into the locker
room early we were in pittsburgh came in
early tried to get warmed up
i'm like i'll be fine i'll be fine and
pop some pills
uh i get off the table and i'm like [ __ ]
i
still my back is still seizing up i go
and lie down
in the locker room and i'm looking up at
my offensive coordinator
and our head coach and they're like ed
can you go and i'm like yeah and i tried
to get up i couldn't get up there like
all right up you're not playing today
so it was a game time decision and it
took about another month for them to
realize that i had an infection in the
disc
uh which was oh
man you know it was uh i had to go on
eight weeks of intravenous antibiotics
a nurse came to my house every day and
injected me with these
well this is this is insane yeah you go
from feeling like it's much better the
piece of glass is out
so now it's like you're i couldn't walk
around my house i was paralyzed
it was the monday after that we'd come
home and we had a monday night game
against baltimore
and i was like i'll be good to play you
know and i'm
walking from the player's parking lot
into the facility
and literally i was brought to my knees
with a spasm in my back
um so i was done for the year again
eight weeks intravenous antibiotics
that's so insane
every day nurses come in yeah every day
nurse is coming my wife is pregnant at
the time
so it was a bit of a blessing i got to
be home and be with that
and you know and experience the birth of
my child
which was really a life-altering
experience
um melting of the man's heart
big time big time and just seeing the
the strength of my wife and her power
as a woman and it's incredible you know
that's a podcast in itself
um but so
i was about ready to be done at that
point um
yeah well actually you know to be honest
with you man
no because that was my third year that's
just three seasons
it's crazy that's three seasons yeah
yeah yeah yeah so i worked my ass off
got back
in the midst of being at home recovering
from this
this infection in my back i had
i'm watching the today show i turn on
the today show one morning and i see
jacksonville jaguars team sold head
coach
fired that's how i found out that uh
because i wasn't going they didn't want
me going into the facility anymore
at that point it's with the infection
and just
you know keeping it as safe as possible
so i find out the team's been sold head
coach is fired so i'm like hey man
i'm just gonna [ __ ] it you know i have
one more year on my contract i'm gonna
work my ass off you know come back and
have a great fourth year
i do that i come back got a new head
coach this guy mike malarkey
um which his name says it all and
uh it was a terrible year
you know i had completely
lost my love for the game i'd lost i'd
give it you know i
i felt completely betrayed i was benched
four games into the season after the
first game of the season
we're playing the vikings and i have a
dude thrown into my left ankle
did a low high ankle sprain
which really should have been a six to
eight week recovery
they have hurried me back in two weeks
like eb you should be able to play
i'm like i'm all right man but i can't
push to my i can't push off my left leg
to move right
like you should be fine i'm like okay so
i did it you know and i got my ass
kicked in a game against the bengals
got benched at halftime and that just
completely
shattered my confidence my trust in the
team
you know for me football had been such a
family
experience you know these coaches were
my father figures my
you know these were my people my family
my
and all of that i felt completely
betrayed no one could really
talk to me about what was going on i was
trying to figure out you know
why am i being benched i worked my way
back got
earned the starting spot back the next
week and then
was benched for the rest of the season
and i just took myself out of it at that
point
so after that season i was really ready
to be done i mean the team went
1-15 that was that's a
really painful yeah it's horrific i mean
it's already
painful to be you know sort of a seven
and
nine year but one in 15
guys you're making your your off-season
plans in october
you know yeah because you're 0-8 and you
just know where the season's going
it's not fun you know and there's this
balance between what you're describing
as
coaches and brotherhood and family with
also some strange perverse capitalistic
incentives
where it's like yeah well if you can no
problem
two weeks high ankles low low high
ankle sprain a high ankle sprain is
really bad
that sometimes requires surgery but i
had a low
high ankle sprain so it was
on the cusp so i didn't need surgery but
it needed a good
solid recovery time to repair you know
and yeah i mean that's you know it's
egos are involved there's
all sorts of you know
psychological things happening take some
of the
pharmaceuticals some of the painkillers
yeah and
you know perform so there's this that
whole like kind of gladiator mentality
that you're talking about it's like
taking
the player and throwing them on before
they can actually
heal fully yeah and that's so there's
that balance between that too but yeah
four years man you went through a
ridiculous
amount in four years in the nfl and for
the jegs and
i mean we're talking all the shoulder
dislocations the herniation the
surgery the infection um the low
high ankle sprain the um
the shattering confidence having to get
back on
earning your spot back go about to be
all pro but not and then
having or one in 15 i mean
yeah this is nuts going through the
change in ownership and coach
in like all of the with the birth of
your daughter
as well through that process i mean
that's a nuts
four years and it definitely births a
beautiful
treasure into the world however having
all of that experience
oh yeah man yeah absolutely you know it
wasn't even the bears yet
yeah yeah exactly well you know just to
finish it up
i was about ready i was ready to be done
after four years
talked to my wife talked to my father
in particular um talked to
some teammates so he had this incredible
teammate in the jags his name's brad
meester who's
starting center for them for 14 years
i said brad man i think i'm [ __ ] done
you know i don't know if i could do this
anymore he said
i think that every year
he goes you know man i think that for
the last you know however many years he
said i
i think that every year i'm done after
this
and he says wow i just give it one more
shot
you know and see how it is and he said
to me he's like you know man i know how
you feel
see how it goes you know maybe give it a
shot
let another get yourself signed by
another team maybe you find your love
for the game again
yeah maybe you're re-inspired to play
and if not you know you're done yeah so
i said okay
so i had a couple workouts i went worked
out for the seahawks
and you're like about 30 yet or like 26
25. wow yeah yeah oh my gosh you're
only 25 or 26 yeah
at the time at the time yeah and you
went through all of that
yeah yeah holy [ __ ]
yeah so i go i work out for the seahawks
they were like we'll let you know if we
want to sign you
uh i fly from
jacksonville to seattle spend 24 hours
work out for them meet with everybody
fly back to jacksonville
the next day i get on a plane fly to
chicago
work out for the bears right away
they're like we want to sign you
we want you to stay here you know
so from that moment on i
and it was like i was in tears i didn't
know if i wanted to do it anymore and
here this team wanted to offer me a new
contract so i thought that was great
you know um yeah and i just took it and
i sort of
you know played it as it was
and sort of fell in love with it again
had a great year got to be the sixth
swing tackle
and they carved out this nice blocking
tight end monster tight end role for me
which i was really successful at and i
brought a lot of production to the
offense the
chicago tribune even wrote an article
about
how much more productive the offense was
when i was in there
so i'd play like 20 to 30 snaps a game i
was perfect
you know and i fell in love with it i
was kicking ass yeah
i didn't have to be a starter
it was a great bunch of people chicago's
an incredible sports town
it was a great experience i lived right
in the city
you know and so it was a great
football it was the football experience
i needed to
feel good about being done you know yeah
and also have a good taste
of the game as well yeah yeah and it was
like this is what
delivered that yeah yeah so i
i had a one-year deal there and after
that year i thought man i could really
get a solid free agent
contract out of this nothing really came
so i signed back with chicago for one
year and at that point all the magic was
gone
the coach's egos got really saturated
and the energy of the team
the team fell apart all the all the
magic of that first year in chicago is
really gone
you know and i have to i mean football
is an
energy game it's all energy it's the
ultimate team sport and it's a trickle
down from the top
you know so the success of a team on
sunday is really a
it's it's a um
it's a extension or it's a
illumination of the success of the inner
team
you know what i mean that's right so
ownership front office head coach
coaching staff
players you know it all works down
and so the more that the
inner world of everyone involved is
enlightened yeah and in alignment and in
alignment
yeah it all flows on the field it all
flows on the field on sunday and you
know
and the juxtaposition of that is so true
about entrepreneurship
right you know yeah of course companies
of course
so it was a beautiful experience you
know looking back in my football career
it was such a
beautiful experience of understanding
concepts of success or the
concept of success what makes something
successful
you know and it all comes back to the
same thing
you know whether it's the microcosm of
your individual life or the macrocosm of
your company's success
it all comes back to the same thing are
you in alignment
with your truth are you in alignment
with your energy
you know and so looking back
that all of that all the pain all the
[ __ ]
trips to the hospital the surgeries the
the
crushing lows the the devastation of
my confidence and my trust in myself and
trust in
the people around me who i was working
with
it all gave me the
knowledge and experience necessary to do
what i'm doing now
that's it you know yeah so i mean
there was a time where
football or talking about all of this
was really painful and difficult
and even watching football i couldn't
watch football for the last
three or four years and this year i'm
watching just about every game
just because i have such an appreciation
for the dance
yes you know the art of that you know
the art of competition um
and i can love that and i can be in that
and uh
i feel super blessed man it's fun to to
come and talk about
it and and to re-uh
dive into that
old box of memories
because it gives me new context around
the experience
you know you're now diving into it from
a much more
enriched wiser perspective and yeah it
does
it's like revisiting that book or movie
or song after several years of the
evolution of one's own
awareness so one more thing on that
before you jump in
you know i was for a long time and this
goes into something else i've been
thinking about you know i looked at my
career as a failure
you know my football career because i
had this idea i'm going to play 10 years
in the nfl i'm going to do this i'm
gonna become this
so for a long time i was draped in shame
and doubt and this uh
feeling like my football life was a
failure
you know and so
like you said being able to apply that
lens of
wisdom and distance from it now i have
such a great appreciation for it all
all right let's hit this from so many
different angles all right one of the
angles is that
like athletes
have this incredible
relationship between the mind and the
body as a vehicle
in order for it to execute whether it's
football soccer basketball
hockey baseball tennis golf
sports that are team driven sports that
are solo driven
and there's a ridiculous amount of
people
on the planet that have been through
this sort of athletic
process where it's a
it's this realization in in some way
over time
that occurs which is that this body is a
divine
vehicle and that
we have to do a better job at
individually taking care of it and also
having the incentive structures
in the sports industrial complex let's
say that
takes care of the true soul
and not kind of having that
perverse incentive of trading out cogs
in a machine type
thing and so there's we got to have that
more holistic health-driven
soul-driven perspective on it yeah and
then the other thing that you were
mentioning i thought was super
interesting was kind of like
in a sense this is in chapter six of
high level perception
this part on the evolution of
consciousness where
it's almost as though whether the it's
happening in the
sports arena or whether it's happening
in the entrepreneurship arena as we were
saying or whether it's happening in the
civilizational
arena the more that you have people in
places of power that have egoic levels
of consciousness
the more you're going to have misery
unfold and
the more that you have people that have
experienced transpersonal or non-dual
states of consciousness higher level
states of unity
god consciousness the more the they
realize
the self in the other and then there's
no interest to
self deal and and hoard and have
perverse incentives for
just one's own sake yeah and so
this is really important because it ties
into that first
thing that i was saying which is that
overall um realizing that
mind body spirit complex and that soul
that's there
and treating it that way with the next
generation architectures that are more
around flourishing and less around
extraction
and stuff like that that was i think a
key takeaway now i want to ask you the
question around
how did you identify that throughout
that entire process
that rather than using
painkillers opioids that there was this
revelatory process for
humans that was unfolding which was the
emerging market of cannabis and healing
through that
and then take us through kind of also
like the activist process in these
last couple of of years yeah it's a
great question
i can't believe you only went six years
but you underwent all of this insanity
compressed in a six
year yeah it's kind of mind-boggling
thinking about it
um
[Music]
i always gravitated towards
cannabis or plant medicine
i remember when i was like
15 or 16 it might have been sparked by
watching the movie altered states have
you seen that movie
william hurt he's a
scientist who goes to mexico
and he gets peyote and he starts going
and
does doing these peyote trips and then
he brings it back to new york
and he's doing all this [ __ ] these
tests in his lab with a float tank and
he'll take the peyote you know get in
his float tank and he devolves into like
a caveman
wow and then he runs amok in the city
and so he's like
experimenting with this and uh
eventually he goes haywire because he
starts doing it too much and his
at the end he's like fighting through
a complete decomposition of his physical
body
uh which is it's really interesting um
and terrifying um
i recommend it for anybody who's
interested in these
these sorts of ideas but i had this
interesting calling or gravitation
towards doing a peyote journey
i still haven't done that peyote sort of
got quiet
throughout my uh you know football
career in ayahuasca
emerged as i sort of started down the
spiritual path
but cannabis was always very intuitive i
was always very
interested and curious about it
so really my i did it you know i smoked
weed once or twice in high school and
had
very intense experiences very terrifying
like didn't want to do it again uh and
it wasn't until
college when it was at the end of the
season
we were all it was a a get-together of
all the o-linemen
we had a bonfire in the backyard and
someone brought a joint we started
passing this thing around
and you know it was it was a great
experience of brotherhood and
uh sort of ceremonially
putting a period on the season and that
experience that we had all been through
together
yes great hardship great physical
hardship
giving it everything we had being
physically and emotionally exhausted
from the year
and really getting to come together and
have this moment this ceremonial moment
of
togetherness and brotherhood and
acknowledging what we had been through
together
and i remember waking up the next day
and i said my god
if i had been up drinking alcohol all
night i'd feel like
hell today but i feel like i could go
play football again right now
and i carried that with me
it was really it was so intuitive it was
so such a
a real experience of feeling
as though i had been healed in this way
you know obviously i wasn't totally
healed but energetically i felt
rejuvenated so i always kept that in the
back of my
in the back of my nervous system i guess
you could say
so dealing with cannabis throughout your
college career
is very tricky there's drug tests all
the time they're at random you never
know when they're going to happen so you
can't really use cannabis
in college as an athlete i think you
also wrote in one of your posts
that you can use cannabis in the mlb
and is it in the nhl is the other one uh
i believe
mlb doesn't test for it i don't think
the nhl
tests for it or if they do test for it
there's no punishment as long as there's
no issues happening no on the field or
on the ice or off the ice issues
happening that
are of concern but in the nfl cannabis
is under the substance of abuse test
which is an
annual drug test and you generally you
have an idea of when that test is going
to happen it's going to happen sometime
between when you first
report to the facility in the spring
around april it can happen anytime from
that day
to about the first week of training camp
so you've got
april may june july august about a five
month window
where you have to be very mindful
because this
annual substance of abuse test could
come any time
but once that test happens you're free
to use
cannabis at will oh interesting
so once you get a hang of that you know
you talk to the guys sort of you know
the cannabis users they come
they come together you know yeah they
they find each other in the locker room
and i was always very difference between
the psychoactive
thc components and then the more uh
bodily rejuvenating potentially other
cannabinoids cbds this type of stuff
huge difference like that definitely but
at that time you know
there wasn't all of this there wasn't i
was getting a bag of wheat you know from
the
trusted the trusted team dealer you know
uh there was no cbd tinctures
and this strain and that strain it was
just you know pay
way too much for an ounce of you know
god knows what um
and i would say i would argue that you
know
this idea of recreational cannabis use
you're
most people if you're using cannabis
you're using it to
self-medicate for some one issue or
another whether that's to de-stress
or to deal with back pain whatever it
might be
creative strategy is another one that we
so there's the medicinal side of it
sleep as well and digestion and all
these other pain all this other stuff
but then
there's rare diseases that are healed
with large doses of
hemp cbd we've had people on earth oh
definitely
definitely but then there's also the
creative strategy side of things which
is super
interesting because what happens is
there's the in neuroscience we have
default mode network and what micro
dosing micro dosing enables is the slow
releasing of the grip and then you
enable new creative connections to
happen
as long as you basically anchor the
creative strategy session
in execution like the next week the next
days and the next week
that way you actually actualize the
goals rather than
only staying in creative strategy mode
anyway there's the creation i love that
yeah yeah you get very nuanced yes
obviously
um but so as gladiators as warriors i
found cannabis was very intuitive
you know many guys i say fifty percent
uh one of my teammates on the bears
marty bennett
martellus bennett it was a great tight
end when he came out of his career he
said that he thought
more like 75 percent of guys use
cannabis
um so there's that so i used it very
intuitively
you know it became it was a very
intuitive medicine for me as my physical
body
wore down and my emotional body
was in a constant state of stress
cannabis was really the one thing i
could come home i could smoke a little
weed and i could feel totally
decompressed i could leave football
there
and i could relax i could rejuvenate i
could get a great night's sleep
meanwhile having all having this
experience this firsthand experience of
being handed a thing of opiates
taking a prescribed dosage feeling
irritable
insane rage at the surface of my
consciousness when i'm in
the most vulnerable position you know
dealing with a dislocated shoulder
having a herniated disc in my back where
i literally needed people to help get my
get myself dressed
i needed help doing everything i was in
a state of complete chaos
waking up at two or three o'clock in the
morning with withdrawal symptoms
on a prescribed dosage three days in
um i've i've since since coming out of
my football career i had a dna test on
where it said that i have a variance in
my
genetic sequence that makes me highly
susceptible to
opiate side effects which is really
interesting
so opiates i i knew they just weren't
they didn't work for me
you know they made me feel really insane
really
intolerant uh they didn't do much for
the pain
they made it really difficult to sleep
and get rest and heal
so cannabis really intuitively i kept
coming back to it because
i could decompress physical emotional
psychologically
psychologically i could get a good
night's rest i could
come home and connect with my family and
friends i could
you know live a
decent level quality of life
you know for the amount of pain that i
was done
so coming out of my football career and
towards the end in chicago i don't think
i took any
opiates anymore i used
as my as far as pain management goes i
used cannabis
basically solely as my choice for pain
management
during my last couple years
um so i come out of my football career
like i said i was completely obliterated
physically emotionally spiritually
mentally had no idea who i was complete
loss of identity
no idea what i was going to do to make
money put food on the table
jeez that's another thing is the whole
athlete
after career thing yeah gosh that's
another big
beast that nobody [ __ ] talks about
enough yeah absolutely
and what about the money that is being
made while the players are in the
athletics as well yeah to be able to
actually
allocate that adequately towards
long-term wealth creation so that
afterward that we have the
yeah yeah and this is it's all good
right yeah we're yeah we're good this
time that was just an update virus
protection
one yeah yeah yeah we're good this time
so
yeah that's another nut stick yeah yeah
i mean that's the whole podcast in
itself
yeah we have to be set up for that
long-term wealth creation and also to do
things
after age 30 or after age 40 if you go
10 years or 20 years
or 5 or 15 or however long but we have
to be set up
to do something and there could be a
whole industry
in just working with athletes on
long-term wealth creation and doing
things after they
finish their careers yeah that could be
a whole interesting industry
okay absolutely and you're going to get
these little like
bits from me because these are things
that i've been thinking about for a long
ass time
yeah we just don't we we haven't had
enough athletes come on the program
to unpack this type of stuff so you're
you're pulling some
really good triggers from me on wanting
to
correct perverse incentives think long
term about these types of things so
i love it yeah it's great man um
so i'm sitting there what am i going to
do what am i going to do with my life
and my wife goes well it's time to write
your book
i had a stack of journals from the time
i was in college just keeping notes
throughout
she says now it's time to write your
book and i said okay
uh it's a great idea god bless my wife
you know
um so i started writing a book
uh my football agent passed me off to a
literary agent
went down the rabbit hole wrote up a
whole book proposal
publishers liked it but they wanted
either more dirt or the red carpet story
of a peyton manning a tom brady so
what does that mean um they just wanted
more glitz and glamour or they wanted it
to be a more
i i don't know talk [ __ ] on people i you
know i don't
i don't know i was like well this is the
story it's charles bukowski
yeah exactly as an offensive line then
yeah i love that
yeah that that's actually funny you only
now
after you say that is there some sort of
like visual
resonance to me but it totally makes
sense now
yeah go all the way yeah yeah
that's you that's for sure you know yeah
man
so they didn't like that though well i
think that a lot
a lot of people liked it um
i think they liked it there was great
feedback some of the publishers who are
most interested
said well we already filled our our
uh sports book quota for the year so we
have to
pass it's that thing we talked about you
know the corporate publishing
monsters you know so i was like okay man
so i wrote this article i wrote a
massive article
for sportsillustrated.com
and it got a huge amount of reach
um i even had you know old athletic
trainers calling me saying how the [ __ ]
could you say all this
and i was like dude i didn't name you i
didn't i
really i was just talking about my
experience and
from the heart i don't know what else to
say you know you want me to
say that he was like you painted us like
we didn't give a [ __ ] and i was like no
i didn't
you know i thought i painted the coaches
more like they didn't give a [ __ ] but
um you know it was what it was it was
what it was
you know yeah so i had a very heated
exchange with
my former head athletic trainer from the
jags god bless him mike i hope
you're out there lots of love to you man
but so it it sparked this new thing
of uh then i got a call from a producer
who's doing this documentary take your
pills which is on netflix which
documents my whole
adderall experience which is a whole
other thing
um but then i get connected to
so cannabis was this very integral part
of my healing experience throughout my
football career so i got connected to
this guy
kyle turley was one of my childhood
heroes all pro
offensive tackle we had had the same
agent
he was very much the tip of the spear in
the
cannabis as medicine for pro football
players movement
is that's is that called neuro xpf yes
that's his company that's his cbd
company neuro xpf
and believe it or not nero xpf and
again kyle turley turley
yeah kyle turley shout out because yeah
love kyle because
kyle turley and neuro xpf are what
are what sarah baker
and kristen price from
hoop beauty use
to heal their rare cluster of diseases
and they use those large doses of hemp
cbd
neuro xbf in order to be able to heal
and they
traveled around the world to different
physicians to the best of the best
and they could not figure out how to
heal
that cluster of rare diseases and they
were they're teenagers bro they're
teenagers
they can't get through
the rare cluster of diseases they're
undergoing losing hair prom like not
being able to move
grip a pencil etc all this different
type of stuff and
it was kyle turley and nero xpf and mcbd
so i just want to shout out because
that's also coming at an
athletics angle as well we we should
have kyle
on that yeah you should definitely
that's a good one kyle's incredible he's
a revolutionary
um you know through covet he's been
saying
cbd will take care of covet that's it
he's gotten a lot of flack
for that but i think he's right on man
um he's an absolute revolutionary and we
need him so
i got connected with kyle and kyle said
this was probably five years ago now
kyle said ebb i'm
doing a cannabis conference out in
phoenix i'd love for you to come and
tell your story and speak
you know at the time i was like man uh
all right
i don't really know what else what i'm
gonna say but
i guess i'll just say how cannabis
helped how i feel cannabis helped me
during my nfl career etc
so i was like yeah kyle i'd love to
anyway i can support you because
you know he was such a prototype of what
i was seeking in my football experience
so i go to this cannabis conference in
phoenix
and it's kyle turley nate jackson who
played
tight end for six years for the broncos
also new york times bestselling author
one of my good friends
uh i highly recommend his first book
slow getting up which is
an incredible detailing of the football
experience
uh ricky williams and me and we're in
this
huge conference hall there must have
been 500 to a thousand people
and i'm looking around this room and
it's military veterans and it's cancer
survivors and it's these families with
treve syndrome
these mothers of children who have these
severe seizure disorders
[Music]
who have all been healed by cannabis
yeah
you know and here we are having played
professional football
and you know beyond i don't i don't know
for me there was no really other way i'm
just sort of following
god at that stage you know and i'm
telling my story i don't know what it
means and i say i tell my experience of
how
i use cannabis just about every day
throughout my football career and dealt
with all these injuries and how i feel
like i came
out of my career in better shape because
of it
i'm looking around this room and i'm
just sort of in awe at the breath
of people that this affects in a
positive way
and so next up comes kyle turley and he
starts talking and he opens up with
the federal government has a patent on
cannabinoids as
neuroprotectants and antioxidants that's
patent
six million six hundred and thirty
thousand five oh seven
and i'm just like whoa what the [ __ ]
and he goes on to say how through
scientific studies the
you know uh department the nih
um these government bodies
governing scientific bodies have done
all these scientific studies to see
how cannabinoids can help
heal the brain from damage and can also
help prevent
damage before it occurs in in the brain
they have a patent on it cannabinoids is
neuro protectants
and antioxidants and you write about
this
in your blog post on the subject yeah
and it blew my mind
you know it [ __ ] blew my mind and
then he goes on to talk about how we all
have an endocannabinoid system in our
bodies
and our bodies produce our own
endogenous cannabinoids
mirror replicas of the cannabinoids
found in the canvas plant
anandamide the bliss molecule to perform
all sorts of issues you know our
endocannabinoid system is
involved in how we feel and deal with
pain our appetite our sleep rhythm
and our mood among
myriad other things so
my mind is blown and all of a sudden my
entire experience as a football player
because i was coming from this place
you know my cannabis use throughout my
football career i kept it very private
because as a team
captain as a team leader as a guy that
coaches always look to to set the
example for the team
my inner
dialogue about my cannabis use was
wrapped in
shame it was i can never let anyone find
out about this because i'll lose all
credibility as a leader in this locker
room
so my whole experience came to this
crystallized point
and it was all validated and legitimized
when i learned about this and it just
set this [ __ ]
fire in my in my heart you know i need
to learn as much as i can about the
history and science of this plan
how it works and um it validated
everything and it really
set me on this path of
to not put too fine a point on it it's
being a truth teller man yeah
and seeking out the truth especially
when there's such a
wide breadth of people that have been
healed
thanks to cannabis and now you're
with the help of what kyle's saying yeah
neuroprotective antioxidant
endocannabinoid system what's actually
going on
on a planetary scale with the secretion
of this and all of the different
cannabinoids all the different dosages
all the different applications of it
and so meanwhile you know meanwhile my
football brethren are
in dire straits guys are being diagnosed
with early onset alzheimer's and
dementia
cte chronic traumatic encephalopathy
which is really the
you know the major issue affecting
football players at this stage which is
a degenerative neurological disorder
caused by the sub concussive hits and
the constant
hits to the head and i'm like here's
this medicine
it's a [ __ ] medicine for this so i
formed an organization called athletes
for care which was basically all of us
ex-pro athletes who had had this
experience which was a lot
and continues it seems like every day
there's people coming out of the
woodwork talking about how cannabis has
affected them
in a positive way and i think really it
comes down to this
you know corporatization corporatized
mindset
and the athlete you know i can't say
the truth about my experience because
i'll lose endorsements i'll lose my
contract i'll lose this and that
and uh you know for whatever reason i
was
i was blessed with a very uh
anarchical stance and a
um a passion for
resisting the powers that be and the the
so-called authority figures that
claim to make all the rules and you know
break through all of that with just the
truth of the experience you know
so it was a very powerful
thing that happened for me in my life
after football to really
set me into what it is i'm here to do
you know
yeah man
seeing the brothers in athletes seeing
the
the sisters in healthcare seeing the
all the different use cases that
indigenous have been
applying it to seeing the
myriad benefits and then seeing the
all the brothers and sisters that are
also jailed um
in that process because of it so um
i mean this is yeah this is a really big
awakening planetary-wise
one thing that i would say about the
emerging market
of of cannabis and hemp
is that and i would say that the same
thing applies for
psychedelics and antiogens and the same
thing applies for
decentralization blockchain
cryptocurrency smart contracts
is that as we have these massive
emerging markets happen
it's super important to inclusively
stakeholder everyone
in the fruits that emerge from them
because usually what happens is that you
get
the people that come in early and make
the investments that reap the vast
majority of the benefits
and then the rest of the people get
breadcrumbs and that
rather it's that everybody should be
steak held
in the growing pie of the
massive emerging markets that are
happening in this case absolutely
yeah so absolutely well yeah that's uh
if you want to get involved there's a
great
uh movement the last prisoner project
headed by steve d'angelo that you can
support and that's all about getting
you know the the non-violent marijuana
possession
people out of jail because there's
hundreds of thousands of
african-american men and women who are
serving way too long
in prison sentences that should be set
free and
you know meanwhile all of this is
putting a lot of money in people's
pockets
yeah meanwhile the dea teamed up the cca
i know i know i know it's horrible and
i'm
grateful we've had steve on the program
and i agree you have
yeah oh nice yeah i love him yeah he's
saves the man
he gave us several times the breakdown
of
you know the multi-decade process that
has that we've undergone with
the liberation of cannabis on the planet
and there's think about all the creative
economic value that the
hundreds of thousands of people um
can be driving to our planet by
absolutely being
just sitting in jail rotting away
absolutely man yeah so
so then now where did that launch you
into
uh you know ebb and flow podcasting you
know book writing
hotbox and mike tyson you know you kind
of
have your your your found passion for
making the case for cannabis to athletes
and disseminating that
so yeah walk us through these last
especially a couple of years
[Music]
so i started athletes for care which
really provided this new community of
like-minded individuals and also to
establish a safe third party
resource for athletes coming out of
their careers
to come and get information education
financial opportunities work
opportunities etc
through that you know i met a lot of
good people and you know i'm
always seeking out the
my alignment with the universe you know
um i'd always had this
obviously there's uh the love of writing
which writing is sort of the
it's like going into the gym for your
mind you know
uh for me it's uh
to take the ideas that are happening in
here and put them into
some concrete format whether that's on a
pad of paper or in a computer etc
um you know it's it's a great way to
flesh out ideas and
come to terms with things and figure
things out and understand
concepts and synergize ideas etc
but beyond that i had a radio show in
jacksonville
i got to know the the music director of
the local npr station
i became really good friends with him
and he said ebb i have some open
slots that i need to fill do you want
your own radio show
i said hell yeah dude you know i came in
and got to hang out with him one day and
um i was doing a charity event at the
time
and he said we could pub we could do a
little pr
on your charity event and why don't you
bring in a playlist of music and
we'll play that as well and we could
talk and i'll show you
how i do things so i just fell in love
with it
he gave me my own time slot i got to
make my own show called the number 73
she could probably find somewhere uh
where i did playlists of music
intertwined with um
poetry readings literary experts
or excerpts um you know and i would make
it all in a theme so one was dreams one
was my
you know childhood in brooklyn you know
um so that
and i remember also having this
experience
i think about it a lot these days i
would be in the locker room
and just loving the exchange the
conversation in the locker room
you know you'd have a dip in on you know
20 milligrams of adderall
talking to a guy about all kinds of [ __ ]
you know and i thought to myself i'd
love to have a job where i get to talk
to people
in life after football um at one point i
thought maybe that was
psychiatry or being a psychologist
which i'm s you know that's very
deep in everything i'm interested in uh
but that's sort of as because of my
my inner vibration of an artist
it's manifested itself in podcasting
so through the cannabis world like i
said nate jackson was a good friend of
mine he lives down in venice and i said
dude let's start a podcast
so that started with the mindful warrior
podcast
i was like we can just start talking
about this experience of being
ex-football players and life after
football and
how to heal yourself and you know the
process
of figuring life out from the point of
view of an athlete
so it started there
[Music]
that evolved into caveman poet society
we had to change names because there was
a mindful warrior out there already
um in the midst of that
you know i'm still doing we're doing
speaking around the country
around the world at cannabis conventions
talking about cannabis as medicine for
athletes and the benefits of it and
you know protecting against cte or being
a remedy to cte
etc uh so i
was cultivating this
repertoire as being an expert in the
field of cannabis as medicine for
athletes
football players in particular
old team doctor of mine this is now
early 2018
calls me up or maybe oh god it was 2017
calls me up and said ebb i'm coming out
to la next week
mike tyson's cannabis company is putting
on
a cannabis and medicine summit
and i think i would really like to
introduce you to them i know i've been
following your career since you left
and it looks like you're one of the
leading voices in this movement
i said wow okay i mean i met and at that
point i felt as though i had met
a lot of the players in the game i had
no idea mike tyson was even involved in
cannabis
so i said okay i get introduced to mike
and his business partners
i end up having to put on the entire
panel
i emceed it i put together a whole
presentation
i brought in a number of nfl nhl
mma fighters uh some doctors
some neuroscientists to come and do this
really incredible panel that we filmed
uh long story short there they said ebb
this is mike's business people he said
ebb we
we love your energy we want to we want
you to just
keep coming and hanging out here yeah
we'll pay
you said sure you know so that
evolved into eventually they said ed we
want to start up mike's podcast we know
you have a podcast can you help us
produce that
so next thing i know we're starting up
hot boxing
and at the time it was really
interesting meeting mike because he was
in a very dark place he was really
struggling
very much still afflicted by his vices
and in the grips of addiction so
throughout that process the first
episode of hot boxing that you can find
on youtube is with this guy dr
jerry who's a uh
toad shaman 5meodmt
so we brought him in mike did the toad
and uh it was sort of this watching this
miraculous spiritual awakening
unfold throughout the course of that
show
um wow yeah yeah
and you know in the process of that i
really i
i healed a lot of my own
pain through my experience with mike
and seeing this guy who is really a
demigod of american culture
you know he's our modern day hercules
he's been a
unimaginable highs devastating lows
been in prison been you know
charged convicted of rape it's been a
you know just the
complete devastation of his entire life
multiple times over and reimagined
himself and found his way out of it and
re-emerged
and here he is and he's the most
sensitive humble
honest person i'd maybe ever come into
contact with
you know because for him
there was no other way you know it was
basically like
kill yourself or be honest about who you
are
yeah you know and what you've been
through yeah yeah
and uh that really resonated with me and
my journey
you know going back to when i was a
little kid you know and this idea of you
know coming to the middle way
you know we get so attached to who we're
supposed to be and how it's supposed to
look and
what success is and you know the shame
of all our failures
and being wrapped up and not
not realizing all of these
dreams and fantasies and ideas we had of
ourselves early on and
just getting wrapped up in all of that
it's like let all that [ __ ] go man and
just who are you what are you here to do
what's your truth in the moment um yeah
so through that process you know i mean
i
really coming sitting here in front of
you today man
it's the most
in my feet i've been
since leaving football you know yeah and
it's a constant process
you know we took this uh my dad just
just my dad just moved out of brooklyn
new york
lived there for 40 years um
and during high school he actually moved
out of brooklyn
came to l.a saw my brother and i get
through high school
hated l.a moved back to brooklyn
so he's there now again for the last 15
years
he just left brooklyn and moved to
tucson arizona okay
and uh we spent the week there my wife
and daughter
we spent the week there and uh it was
beautiful
you know such an incredible experience i
had this really interesting
thing about my relationship with my dad
and how close we
are emotionally and energetically how
much we've been through together and yet
we've always had this space between us
you know because my parents were
divorced
i got to see my dad once a week and then
at times when we moved across the
country from each other i'd see my dad
once a year
and uh i was feeling really grateful for
this experience of now having him closer
and i actually
i want to move to tucson i want to get
out of la that's kind of where i'm where
i've gotten to
especially through covet and you know my
wife has a thriving
estate planning uh law practice here
which
you know we'll figure that out and maybe
it'll be a partial move at first which
is fine but
towards the end of the trip i was
having this dread sort of descend over
me
and uh you know i feel very deeply it's
one of my gifts
my dad has said to me since i was a
little kid he said abby you're so
sensitive
you know
which at times i took very critically
but that's
really i've come to cherish that my
sensitivity
yes because i feel so deeply
you know i feel
unbelievable highs of joy i feel
soul-crushing lows of despair and
grief and sadness and i was feeling you
know in a lot of my childhood was
draped and dread and uncertainty and
i started having this feeling of dread
and i'm really on this trip over the
last
you know it's all a process you know
seeking the pearl necklace that's around
your neck the whole time
and really getting into that you know
wherever it is because we're constantly
you know in my in my own spiritual
evolution and my conscious evolution
we spend so much time trying to redirect
and get out of the feelings that we're
feeling
and go somewhere else i'm feeling this
i'm uncomfortable i need to do this let
me go jack off let me scroll through
instagram
let me hop into work let me do this let
me do that you know it's like
when is the time to just feel the
feelings that you're having
exactly you know exactly so i started
having this
dread sort of just sort of start to
trickle down
and it was the friday we were leaving on
saturday
and i had this really beautiful
experience of just allowing it man and
just feeling it
being like wow what a what an incredible
experience to be here
and like this is it you know this is
that yeah
this right here yep you know what a gift
yes
you know and it just the dread just goes
away
vanished it disintegrated
it was gone and it was like wow
still here you know self-realization
embodied anchored god consciousness
christ consciousness
unity consciousness it eradicates all of
those roots of misery
it yeah anchors right into the present
moment the bliss
peace joy peace love compassion
for everyone everything yeah perfection
infinite absolute it's
amazing and to consciously
re-baseline to that is the
thing it's the paradox we were talking
about you are both perfect
and you want to work your way into a
place where you can re-baseline that
infinite absolute peace joy bliss
state of being and also become an artist
from that place so you write your book
from that place yeah
every business deal you do comes from
that place every relationship with your
child or your wife or your other friends
comes from that place yeah for other
countries around the world
geopolitically comes from that place
everything comes from that place and
that's
ultimately one of our big keys that
we're
unraveling on the program and trying to
really embody in the awakening in los
angeles because you're
going sounds like might be going to
tucson and we're like well i'm here
you know hey you know it's also that
thing wherever you go there you are
there you are you know and i'm not in
any hurry
it's just uh you know man as my
life as i get older and here i am i'm 33
you know
and i feel like i've lived multiple
lifestyles yeah
it sounds like it my brother that that
six year chunk of time sounds like a
whole lifetime yeah
six years yeah and everything you've
learned and packaged from it and are now
bringing as a treasure
from that yeah so awesome yeah man yeah
so you know it's just i'm slowing down
i'm
i'm sl i said this to someone while we
were there
i said i'm slowing down faster and
faster
that for sure my man you know yeah um
so i just it's like a balance though
yeah oh yeah
i mean i love l.a i convinced my wife to
move back
here you know her family's from pasadena
so i convince i love l.a i love it you
know it's been
always such a
you know you can really express yourself
here
you know let yourself run [ __ ] wild
in a way
and it's not there's no boundary for
that i've always had such a great
appreciation for that
um and i think you know i still have
work to be done here
totally for sure um
but yeah man you know it's like
it doesn't even it re it doesn't matter
where i am it's just like
this moment is it you know yes and you
are like we said you are it you are it
you know
because we suspend we spend so much time
especially in america i think
you know we're we're really the subject
focuses on the object
yeah all the time yeah and it atrophies
the muscle of the subject investigating
its own awareness yes
and realizing that diamond necklace
already around the neck yeah
yeah yeah that's the key yeah we must
get that into the heart of the most
influential people here
we got to do that well that's the thing
or like you said man in 10 years
you know we'll be the most influential
people on the planet
you know we'll be making all the
decisions
so you'll be running for president
that's it yep
i'll be you know somewhere we'll have
our
animated series and mythologies and all
these ways of
memetically disseminating these deeper
self-realizations
yeah as you were telling me about your
story
i found it so cool that you know you had
to seize i just i love sharing these
moments because
you really have to seize the opportunity
that you're given
when you know when kyle is talking to
you about these
cannabis summits and the way that people
are gathering
healing their biggest traumas
and across different industries people
are
healing themselves whether it's athletes
or health care or
any sort of aspect
you put together the panel you put
together the panel of brilliant minds
you have to be a synthesis in order to
do that across those different
disciplines to share those stories
and then you you get exposed because
once you knock knock knock you answer
that door
and you really work hard at setting up
something beautiful what happens is
knock knock knock the next door comes
and the next door something really
another rocketing opportunity your own
podcast
all the guests that you get to feature
on your podcast and learn from like a
sponge
you know the knock knock you know we
trust you with the
mike tyson and his investor group that
wants to really rocket cannabis to the
next level also rocket healing
yeah mike sounds insane by the way the
ups and downs
because those you know your ups and
downs are nuts
a lot of other people's ups and downs
are nuts mics are insane
and but to find
where he is and now sharing his
treasures
with you on the program and you act as
this really
nice catalyst because mike kind of
leans back a lot and kind of
inserts wisdoms strategically
and you kind of draw out the wisdoms of
the guest
that's on the program and also insert
your strategic philosophy and wisdom
along the way and i think that he
definitely needs that
and that you work at a good spot in that
process and so
you're basically both advocating for
in a sense awakening to
the both the healing
processes that occur from the
traumatic unfoldings of people's insane
ups and downs
but also really shining those treasures
and catalyzing the shining of the
treasures on the other side of those
you guys are both catalysts for that and
so yeah you have
you have many strategic
metaphysical perspectives that are
enabling you to be
that shining beacon right now and and
even our back and forth today is
really deeply resonant it's like very
much so a part one
of a where you flower as
your unique aroma of who you are as your
conscious agent
and it's very much so highlighting the
journey
and i just i know that part two and
beyond
are like really focusing in on
what we just unpacked there which is
that god consciousness
that exists right here right now but
that we
atrophy the muscle of the awareness and
that consciousness of investigating its
own nature
and especially children that we must be
the catalyst for them to do that process
that then enables the sustainable
development goals to be solved and so
many other things that we want to
that we want to do yeah yeah
i really want to snap people out of
the illusion that they're living under
you know
taking life for granted because that's
really like
a big issue of this whole thing
people just take life for granted yeah
you know
i was thinking about this the other day
and even sitting here with you
you know when you're really
it's funny it's funny because you spend
your entire
life viewing the world and the people
around you
through this very specific lens
like even when we're here like
communicating and
having this dialogue and sitting across
from each other
you know there is this perspective this
this
lens this
container put around it of me being the
interviewee and you being the
interviewer
yeah you know and so my mind just
naturally starts to put all sorts of
expectations and
uh perceptions around what you're gonna
say
so that i can be prepared to respond in
a specific way
and i was thinking about this with my
wife the other day and i'm sitting there
and i'm
watching her and i'm looking at her and
we're talking and
i just think to myself my god look at
how magnificent this
is you know yes like how magnificent it
is to sit
in front of this being
who is a just a completely fluid stream
of life
happening and yet you know my mind is
because you know once you it's a process
you know i have an issue with guys like
for instance sod guru
i don't know if you know much about sad
guru yes who's a great
i'm balanced about that i think we're
great spiritual
teacher but he also you know he has this
thing where he said there's
no basically it's all here
stop trying to do anything there's no
process
there's no nothing it's it's there it's
you're there already
and while that is true and the other
thing you know that
uh is it is it roomy or it's yeah roomy
about the pearl necklace
that you're always seeking is around
your neck yeah so there is that
you are everything you ca in your
container there is everything you will
ever need to be
all that you are and all that you are
destined to be
in this universe you know but at the
same time there is a
process of realization
that's it you know especially when
you're in the modern era that's it
yep because we've been programmed and
conditioned with so many layers
of relatability and understanding and
and uh perspective so you know in my
relationship with my wife i'm sitting
there and i'm having a discussion with
her
and i'm noticing wow i've got this sort
of there's this
veil of perception where i'm
relating to my wife through an expected
flow of dialogue yeah
but when i let go of that that's it yeah
i have no idea like dude like you and
it's like it's so when you let go of
that
and and it's not like you can just do
that
you know you can't really do that
without putting the work in it's a
muscle
yeah yeah exactly
you really step into the magic of life
you know enlightenment is a habit yeah
and so we re
we re baseline ourselves yeah
into that place that you speak of and it
ends up just transforming
our energy completely one of the one of
the most
i think important things to do in this
process is to do what we call
omni-level perception right teddy coso
brought this up when you share
love doctor exactly yeah exactly yeah we
both had him on
yeah exactly um
because what it means to have omni-level
perceptions it means that
you can take on the perspective of
everything happening at once
and that means that means outside of my
own
conscious agent perspective i go to
well what's what's ebb feeling right now
how is he
perceiving me while i'm perceiving him
and how's the audience perceiving this
and how's china doing and saudi arabia
doing
and kenya like what are they up to right
now like can i hold the whole planet
at once can i hold that whole omni-level
perception happening
and then that's only this planet you
know that's
that's not that's this one song universe
out of everything that is potential and
so
yeah when we when we start expanding
ourselves to that degree like even for a
moment there i just
you know like my everything became way
less dense
i felt way more light
and i'm curious once we take our visions
to the next level
and we keep creating that as we talk
about when we can fill
50 000 people into sports stadiums
that's empty 90 of the time and we
put them in there for a full day on
what we're talking about right now wow
yeah one day man we're going to do that
we are going to do that
again probably be sooner than we realize
yes
you know yes dr ted said the most
incredible thing i think i've ever heard
uh when he talked about enlightenment he
said
ev everybody thinks enlightenment is
about what you
gain and really enlightenment is about
what you lose
you know and i was like [ __ ]
that's it man you know just the letting
go
the constant letting go you know
i have a practice where
i'll take walks i love walking walking
is one of my favorite things
um and walking and breathing
yeah and i'll breathe in
and on every exhale i'll just think to
myself let go
let it go let it go let everything go
you know because you're also
subconsciously you're holding on to all
kinds of [ __ ] you don't even realize
yeah you know you're holding on to all
sorts of things
yeah you know and like you're we're
doing the
we're doing the show notes which we have
to do you know we have to have this
we have to have this this perspective to
relate to
from you know we can't really you can't
come in here
as a as a being of light it's like
no one gets it there's no context what
you're bringing up right now is so
fascinating i was just thinking about it
like 10 minutes ago while we were
talking is like
what is most optimal let's say let's
just do an
experiment right now okay let's say that
let's say you come on the show right and
this is usually what would happen on
episode two with a guest
because usually in episode one what i
try and do
is i try and unpack the really
basically the roots of the seed
and its fruits right and so that way
people
when they feel your aroma in part one
it's usually the fullness of your aroma
from top to bottom as much as we can and
then in part
two usually what happens is we can dive
right into the metaphysic and the
consciousness and
and the and all the other kind of
abstractions but also embodiment work
that we're talking about right here at
the end
now my question would be what if in part
one
we just went there and
i don't know yet i don't i don't know
yet because
it depends it feels strange kind of
bypassing
yeah that part of first part of it yeah
that's been a big
question of mine and podcasting
because i think to myself
is it interesting doing
because i know how i feel when i have to
go and dive into my
life story and i have to unpack it all
you know yeah but it but to some extent
for me right now who i am that's
necessary to give people an
understanding of what i've been through
where i'm coming from to give you the
goods of
what i know yes yes yes but you have
someone like
tony robbins come on yeah you know or
you have snoop dogg or someone who's
very well known and you can dive right
in because they have this sort of
built-in understanding sure
but sometimes as a podcaster it's like
well let's start with just tell us where
you come from
yeah you know yeah and
i've made it part of
my art with podcasting
let's see how we can tap into who this
person is
through this moment right here right now
where we're at where we came in here
let's jump into the meat of the moment
yeah yeah and let that
let's let's let that fling us
back to this moment in time where such
and such happened
yeah you know what i mean like that so
it would be like if we jump right into
the
consciousness and the metaphysic maybe
there's a
maybe there's a moment where it goes
well
actually on one of the reasons why i
feel this specific way about
the nature of being is because when i
was
22 this happened and then we maybe go
for
three five minutes on that then we come
back to the you know
so there's all these different ways to
explore the
the artistic expression on the canvas of
the dialectic
and i'm still i'm surrendered in
intuitive flow in terms of what
optimization means in that regard
because i know that after doing 700 of
these it just
ends up naturally finding
its way right the star is there but it's
very sandy
in terms of where there's no attachment
there's no craving
yeah um there's no solid
chained up way of having to achieve so
when we talk about the stadium as well
it's that we know intuitively that
that's
within the star and the trajectory and
the planetary awakening
but we're not attached to having it
happen
at sofi stadium in 2023 on june 15th
watch this watch this it's gonna happen
yeah yeah
yeah but it's gonna happen but we're
just we are
loose about yeah but we're also you know
it's funny it's a balance because
the two poles that i like to say on this
are people like
we've been talking about these paradoxes
they're good they're fantastic if you
already are it and you're also
constantly re-baselining
that enlightenment as a habit another
good one for this is where you have
people like
gary vaynerchuk that talk about eating
[ __ ] for 10 years as an entrepreneur
which is true
and then you have peter thiel who says
that why can't you achieve your 10-year
goal
in six months right and so i agree with
those two polls as well
and so it's when you wake up in the
morning
it's not so much about i'm surrendered
to intuitive flow
cool i can just do whatever yeah yeah no
it's like
actually you should still do that show
up today like yeah it's not like i'm
just gonna go to the park instead or
whatever
i know it's very interesting isn't it
it's all a paradox
it's all there it is it's all paradox
yeah
it's an enigma wrapped in a paradox
because of course man i'm surrendered to
the intuitive flow i'm going to make it
to the nfl one day
yes you know yes but the
the steps of manifestation exactly or
actualization
and so you see that thing you visualize
it you know what it looks like it feels
like it tastes like
how it's going to be and then something
happens
in the mind body synergy
where you're you just program yourself
into it
yeah you know that's it um
and that's part of the game going back
to this thing you know if it was all
easy
why the [ __ ] would we be here why would
we do any of it
you know if it was easy everyone would
do it
as my dad always says yeah i have an
interesting thought for you because you
have a nine-year-old daughter
we just had maya on the show yesterday
and it was our first by the way i don't
wanna
yeah i gotta i probably gotta roll
pretty soon
reason why i bring this up is because
children their state of
consciousness their state of awareness
their state of awe
their state of play their state of
creativity their state of
not being dogmatically pressured into
an economic machinery as a cookie cutter
[Music]
as a cookie cut gingerbread cookie like
that
your daughter and you know maya
yesterday
and i would i would look at potentially
what
sort of children can do
to loosen adults up to the investigation
of their own awareness
as they engage with their child or
children in general
because that that's hyper catalytic
for this process that we're talking
about of immersion
the children the child's all of a sudden
you know maya was like let's go on the
roof
and i was like man i've been here three
weeks
and i haven't even went on the roof of
this building i haven't even had the
thought of it
i haven't even had the thought of it
exactly and we went on the roof and hung
out up there for like 30 minutes
yesterday oh yeah
this is the type of stuff i'm talking
about exactly yeah
i feel very blessed you know that my
parents are very much that way like my
dad is
63.
and he's followed his intuitive
you know he's followed his north star
from forever you know
like as of being an artist a painter and
it's never really been about money for
my dad it's been about
creating from his heart space and he
just moved
his whole life from brooklyn new york to
tucson arizona
and created this [ __ ] unbelievable
space for himself and his girlfriend
who's a welder and also an incredible
artist
and my wife and i were talking and my
wife really said that she's like
what an inspiration to see this to have
this example in our lives of what you
can do
you know at 63 you know and my wife
comes from a very sort of
i love my in-laws to death but they're
just very buttoned up and
sort of by the book and you know her
father's uh
a successful 401k like wealth manager
and her mother is a
badass hr executive and
very successful people but they're not
that just wouldn't be sort of a
organic thought process to pick up and
move your entire life to a whole new
place and say
[ __ ] it you know um
and children you know that's such an
important thing
you know we get so rigid in our
conditioning yep
we get so rigid and we get attached you
know
we get attached to what it's supposed to
look like how it's supposed to be
what success is i've got to make this
amount of money
and what if you say forget that
and let the universe take care of that
you know
and just enjoy the the play of life
yes you know yes yes
easier said than done we're going to
unpack a lot more of this
yeah we got to do another one we will we
absolutely will and
i also wanna um
as a as lots of people know um the link
in the bio below to the ebb and flow
podcast is
there the itunes links there you can
also find the spotify link on
on eb's website and his instagram's
great as well it's got a lot of
inspiration on it
and one thing that we're gonna try and
do as well is
we're gonna aim to
actualize the synergies between our
nodal clusters of influence
and so we're gonna hopefully see a lot
of nice interchanges between the
powerful leaders that we have on our
programs and stuff like that definitely
there's that there's so many
great creative thoughts for us the very
last question that i like asking super
silly
what's your favorite food
my favorite food meal or
like one singular piece of food you get
to pick
okay um i would have to say
a great grass-fed rib eye and a salad
green salad with avocado ooh
that's my that's my goat how do you like
your ribeye cooked
you know i always go medium yeah i know
they like to go medium rare but i like
it just a little bit more done
yeah likewise yeah yeah medium wells
kind of thing
just some sea salt sea salt is what you
do yeah interesting
uh and then grass fed
grass-fed thing yeah have you went and
hung out with cows
on on the farm as well no i'd like to
that's a fun thing to do yeah
uh you know i've been a fan of dave
asprey and the bulletproof i sort of
intuitively found my way to
just very intuitively found my way to
intermittent fasting and a ketogenic
diet
yep that just works really well for me
and i'm
currently reading uh superhuman by dave
asprey and um you know just listening to
his breakdown of the minutia of
healthy fat and the issues with
industrial meat
i was just loaded with bad fat
and you know all sorts of things it's
really interesting man
and in the midst of it we have this you
know there's a heavy
vegan you know
thing that i think is being dispelled by
the
by the day that's right yeah i would i
would definitely agree with it which is
really interesting
the funny thing is refined sugar is is
[ __ ]
period which is hilarious it doesn't
even matter what you do
yeah it's like everybody knows that all
eight billion people on the planet
should definitely
not be drinking coca-cola in mass which
is so interesting
but then the microbiomes of people are
different for
if they should be more ketogenic or
maybe if they should be a little bit
more
plant-based plant yeah exactly yeah but
it's so funny that refined sugar
is period like for everybody it's really
[ __ ] stay away
that's so stay away i know thank god i
mean i think we're coming to that
realization
as a global culture but
yeah yeah it blows my mind if i see
people drinking soda
i know i haven't had a coke in probably
at least 10 years you know when i see a
person drinking a soda i'm like
[ __ ] really really yeah you know yeah
that's one of the benefits of california
not only is it like the sixth largest
economy
on the planet as a state by itself which
is super interesting but like silicon
valley in hollywood
and san diego are like really obsessed
with health
in many ways and they lead the world in
many ways in that regard
um mental health maybe otherwise and
stuff in l.a but yeah but specifically
health-wise like there's so
many different like dude you can get a
two dollar
like little smoothie thing that actually
has like fruits and vegetables in it
rather than the one dollar coke or
whatever so people are
have figured out that all right lots
more to unpack
so so much more oh my goodness and uh
wow what an epic conversation it was so
lit
that we had the first one cut
the tricaster just shut off super
interesting that that happened very
interesting
we'll stitch these uh together into the
episode that we'll
uh publish as the final here uh shortly
you guys will see that
thanks for tuning in live for all those
that did uh
let us know your thoughts in the
comments below on the episode
on all things that was teaching us about
have more conversations with your
friends families co-workers people
online
about the future of leveraging cannabis
as medicine as healing for us
for all things about the slowing down
the investigation of consciousness and
awareness
of that truth and
[Music]
support the artists the entrepreneurs
the spiritual leaders scientists
engineers in your communities around the
world you can support us our show links
are below you can support us
um follow the ebb and flow podcast
follow him on
instagram as well as links in the bio
below um
check out the itunes and spotify version
it's coming to youtube thanks brother
also yeah which is great yeah thank you
brother
getting better and better at putting it
up on youtube because i know people want
that so
we want to see your emotional reactions
responses that's right thank you
that's it that's it guys that's it much
love
much love build the future manifest your
dreams since the world we love you very
much thanks for tuning in
we'll see you soon
peace